[Music]
happy birthday
[Applause]
look at this
yeah it's so nice wait okay wait wait
let me follow you with the
little okay i like your dress oh thank
you
yeah i like the disco ball all right
i like the wine called chandler and
bennett
dr strange is my favorite can you does
it look good you can adjust
oh i think it looks fine um this is
amazing y'all are so nice i have no idea
oh that was really good i was like and
then i just saw him doing something but
i thought that was for her oh she wasn't
wearing your shield
yeah um this is so nice hi meryl
i've been in a okay great birthday
these are all the people that spotted my
copic birthday
all right so for the first part of your
birthday celebration
okay wow got some birthday messages that
oh if you want to play here you go oh
how do i oh on here
yeah oh this is so fun oh this is so fun
i thought you know like the crew or like
oh kelly clarkson or even mcintyre here
happy birthday girl when you get a
minute let's go celebrate
love you happy birthday i love you
happy birthday kel wish we were there i
hope you have a great day
and i can't wait to spend time with you
this summer and we love you
happy birthday hey kelly it's scott and
i just wanted to say
happy birthday to you
happy birthday we love you so much
have the best day ever happy birthday
kelly we love you so much
happy birthday kelly we love you oh my
god i love you happy birthday kelly
you are one of the kindest human beings
i've ever met in my life you're so sweet
so down to her
i hope you have the best birthday happy
birthday to you
happy birthday to you okay i won't sing
the whole song kelly but happy birthday
um you know out of all the people in my
life who have impacted me
you are easily at the top um you've just
been such an incredible friend and help
you know not only on the show but after
the show you've just been incredible
you know whenever i need help you know
i'm able to reach out to you and that
says a lot to who you are
um and one moment that read that always
comes to mind when i think
you know about how great you are is when
right before the finale you
approached me and asked me um if you
could fly my entire family out for the
finale
and that will always stick with me for
as long as i live how how
incredibly generous and kind that was
and so i hope your birthday is great
here's to 150 more
but happy birthday kelly
yeah it's in summer holidays in your
massive complex universal here that you
have
that you now have because you are just
such a powerhouse
and such a success but furthermore who
cares about being powerful and
successful
you are an amazing human being everyone
that comes in contact with you
everyone that works here so grateful and
proud to be here
and that is just a testament to who you
are
and obviously you know that but i just
want to remind you
that that is who you are in love with
mickey mouse
from a louisiana boy to a texas girl
who went out and done good with that
insane voice
and that amazing personality thank you
from the bottom of my heart
thank you for having me on this show
thank you for being so kind
and compassionate to everyone well
everyone's so nice
happy fifties
oh my god that was amazing 50th this
ain't even my 40th yeah
boy but i don't care i'm ready for 42.
this makes a lot of noise
thank you yeah thank you everybody oh my
god i'm sweating
is it unbelievably hot yeah oh okay okay
i was like is this the change when i am
turning 15 what's
happening now we're gonna play
conversation jenga which is
literally a lot of people are by
themselves for the birthdays this year
because
okay so all you have to do is just write
jenga and then every time you pull out
one
there'll be a number on it and then it
has a question okay can i hand you this
so i can pull this close to me
yes okay that was so nice um okay here
we go
so i just put poke it out right yeah
i have a giant set of this in my 41
41 yeah your idea of a seriously good
time is
well to keep it family
i will think of another one um
[Laughter]
um
a seriously good time okay everything
that's coming across
my brain is not appropriate what does
that mean
um it's inappropriate um
[Music]
you know what a seriously good time is
this is this is pg
um it is is literally i think forever
this can sound like such a mom thing but
just to have like a girls night like
okay for instance i was just surprised
um because i happen to not have my
kiddos this weekend they were with my
ex-husband and so my friends surprised
me
and took me to vegas and we just had a
girls name it was just like the four of
us and
four girls was hanging out and um and it
was fun
the most fun part was they they planned
it perfectly i keep telling trisha this
but it was perfectly planned out and not
too planned
you know there was freedom in the
schedule but there was also like really
cool things like topgolf which was
awesome
um and also will of fortune slot
machines
and well many we did megabooks we did
monopoly we did many
um and then that weird new one the
patriotic one that i kept winning at
anyway um and and yeah glory glorious
i don't know what it was but anyway they
played like patriarchy the whole time
um and then i won a lot i'm on that one
and then lost
um and then anyway it was just kind of
fun and and
i went to dinner and you know got a
dress and a cute hat and
it was really fun and i got to just hang
out with girl i think you know if you're
a parent you don't get those moments of
time so
that was a really long answer um okay
this one's 17.
don't you wish you could hear my real
ones yes
what was your most memorable birthday
um well that one was really cool
especially in my mom years that was
probably
one of the most memorable ones um i
don't know i've had a lot of good
birthdays
i've had a lot of great ones i mean i
guess i'll say
you know it's been kind of a hard year
so this one is kind of really awesome
i think in a completely different way
and i think when you do become a parent
and you know
you love your kids we love our kids with
all our hearts but to have that alone
time to kind of
refuel our tanks um that was pretty
special
so and the best part is they were like
we're flying you private with like 25 of
your closest friends
and it was amazing but it was just funny
because they were like look uh
and i was like i don't care and it was
amazing the whole thing was amazing
and because my friends are funny and
loving and just funny
yeah all right so probably this oh
that's me
okay oh that one was easy that was easy
hit the button 18.
we're gonna go in a row name a song
you'd never sing
for fear of ruining it oh cry cry cry by
judith hill if you listen to the song
you'll quickly realize what i won't
cover it
she has one of the craziest voices on
the planet literally
that's like the only song like that i
mean there's probably other songs that
i'd be like
i wouldn't really pull that off but like
that's the one that like really i one of
the songs that i
absolutely love but i just am like
i'm fine to stay away from it yeah some
people just have other worldly
voices that you just are like no
and there's no way to like make it mine
it's just so hers it's crazy it's good
look it up oh that's me again
next you know what really good at games
asked me to play tic-tac-toe 26.
i feel like i'm playing racco as well
what's a resolution you make every year
on your birthday and do you stick to it
what do you think it is learn a language
learn a language
i don't you know who i'm mad at and girl
he came on here on the show
he knew every rosetta stone language i
bought he
asked me guys i mean because i said i
know a lot of languages right he was
like
he's like yeah and i was like which one
he literally named everyone i've ever
wanted to learn and i was like
i'd kind of just like you but i'm so
impressed
anyway i've always wanted to do that but
i guess truly i don't because i don't
because it's so hard if you're not i'm
the type of person i feel like you have
to live there
or like be around a person speaking it
on the daily
because i i only get so far
in all of them and all my language
things
20 years later still just nailing
english
kind of
oh [ __ ]
name a musician who is incredibly kind
in real life
oh i could name a lot of them um
i can name no no no i was going through
and i literally i just thought of all
females but i can name it males as well
but i
i love um lady gaga was one of the
nicest people um that i ran into there's
actually the beginning of her career
um she was she was really really lovely
um adele really
not only lovely but hysterical um
uh i've met just named people who have
met i've met a lot of people i don't
know i've met a lot of nice people a lot
of country people
um that are nice but i i don't know i
don't know
it's i don't mean it honestly i don't
mean to
meet a ton of turds or anything and i
think when i do
i have this thing that my therapist
tells me where i just like shut it out
like it never happened
um like many things somebody's going to
the bathroom
do you hear the plumbing hope it's going
well
number one or number two yeah it was
awesome they dropped their phone
hopefully not in the toilet
um but no i haven't i only have like a
few
like a small handful of like people i've
met that are i'm like wow you are
you don't have good carbon coming um but
for the most part like most people that
you see me with
i think in general people are nice but
you know what it is it's the test i was
just
talking about this before we walked in
here actually it's the test
of the people around me that don't they
drop something
else somebody is just drunk upstairs or
something
um but no it's the test of the people
around you that people the famous people
like maybe they come on this show or
like come to my show on tour or do
something
in the voice they don't know how close i
am with my people and
i'm going to find out who you really are
yeah they don't know that i'm close to
people so
um like i just found out one that i was
kind of bummed about but i was like oh
secret closet turd okay but like nice to
the famous person
i don't like that i mean just be if
you're going to be a turd be turned to
everyone at least be an equal
opportunist turd
like it's like all right last one okay
48.
i'm long-winded you never get many in
that sorry it's okay
what's one question you want to ask
meryl streep
[Laughter]
do you think i'm crazy
[Laughter]
i think she thinks i'm nuts i think she
probably i think i
definitely scared her on the carpet
here's the thing
i was shocked and i don't hang out at
movie things with like
actors i'm never around actors now i am
but i mean i'm always around musicians
so like you know it's just a weird world
for me and i happen to be at an award
show with actors
and i'm pretty sure i scared her
but i was just so excited and she's so
many of my favorite like she's just such
a
so many my favorite characters in movies
and i i don't even know
honest to god if i ever want to meet her
i know i met her like on the card but i
mean like
actually like because i feel like she
might be afraid of me and i'm so nice
and i just am really inspired and
and she probably thinks i'm crazy do you
think i'm nuts and you know what
that's rhetorical
i know the answer but i'm not meryl i'm
so
lovely um anyway but no i don't really
have here's the thing with famous people
like i'm not i'm not a person that likes
to go
and meet people in general that's why i
kind of messed it up too
because i don't do well i didn't because
i don't know what to i don't know what
just i don't have any like prolific
like things to say i'm just like oh i
like what you do
like and it seems like not enough like
to say that like because that's
that upsets underestimates the value of
your craft but like i don't yeah i don't
really ever know what to say
other than like you're you do really
awesome at what you do you're so
talented
like so i don't i don't it makes me
nervous to meet people i like but are
y'all like that
or do you want to meet people i don't
know either i get so
people think it is snobby it's not
snobby like when they're like you want
to go backstage i'm like kind of not
like kind of not because i i get very
nervous um
but anyway but i love merrell i mean
everybody loves mural that's not like a
that's so rare and unique you know
everybody
all right let's wrap up this guy okay so
let's wrap it up we
have conquered all these numbers look at
this
i won uh or lost um anyway i really wish
i would know what the 49 was
um thank you for hanging out um this is
a surprise birthday
um party and i was surprised that was
well done
um and i'm headed to do another show to
meet people that are gonna be nice to me
but hopefully when i saw my people
bye bye barrel
[Music]